- So Demi has a podcast called
4D with Demi Lovage and it
uses this platform to talk
about finding their identity.
So what was that journey like for you?
Because I feel like when I say "was",
it's kind of a constant thing, right?
We're all ever changing, right?
- [Demi] Yes. I like to think
of myself as ever-evolving.
I feel like if you don't change,
then you're not working on
yourself and I have changed so
much, I've become so much
more of a spiritual person.
I started meditating in
quarantine and lockdown.
- Good on you.
- Well, I think I was just
stoned with nothing to do,
- (Kelly Laughs) Oh my
God, that's amazing.
- But it got me really into meditating.
And so I started meditating
daily and for long periods of
time. And after these intense meditation,
sometimes I would have really
incredible experiences when I
would open my eyes and look up.
And that's why I talk about
how important meditation is to
me. But it also brought me on,
on a personal level that I
was able to go deep inside of
myself and figure out parts
of me that I've never figured
out before. I came out as
non-binary in April or May.
And it's been really, really
cool to see so many people,
so supportive of my journey.
I changed my pronouns to "they/them"
- (crowd cheers)
- And when I try to explain this,
but some people think what
is being non-binary to you?
For me personally, this
isn't the same for everyone,
but I feel spiritually balanced
in my masculine and feminine
energy that I don't particularly
feel more of a woman or a
man. So I identify as non-binary.
- Wow. It's very bold. It's very cool.
Well how can someone who
is not sure how to address,
'cause here's the thing, too,
I always get worried,
because even on The Voice,
like we've had these
conversations with the producers,
because we're turned around,
and sometimes we, yeah.
And so we don't know them.
We're not allowed to know them.
So, so it could be, a they,
a she, a he, we don't know.
And so we turn around and
our big thing is like,
God, we don't want to offend anyone.
Like, you know, so I think
that's the thing that I,
I hate the cancel culture and
like, oh, they're canceled.
Cause they said that it's like, no, no,
give them a minute to learn,
like give them that's the truth, right?
Like, because it's new for everyone.
So if people feel more
comfortable as they/them
I'm totally for that. I just think
you have to allow a little grace, right?
- [Demi] Yes. You have
to have mercy for people
that are trying to learn
this new thing. And for me
I still mess up sometimes
because I was born a female and
was female my whole life
until I started identifying as
non-binary just a few
months ago. So for me,
I even have times where I slip up,
like someone will be like, yes, girl.
And I'm like, yes.
But like, I don't really,
like you know what I mean?
It's not really.
- You're like, so.
- I don't take it personally
when someone's like "yes girl".
I just, I don't know.
I think it's important
that people remember that this is a
new thing and it's absolutely
okay to make an accident as
long as your intention is right.
And that's by like, as
long as it's kind of like,
I had an experience with a
friend who had said, you know,
it's kind of like if someone
were to get your name wrong,
like if someone were to call
you, Carrie, Carrie Clarkston.
- Well, Carrie Underwood,
they've done it a lot.
- [Demi] Oh no! I was just
like, what sounds like it?
- I'm like, we look nothing alike at all,
or but it sounded like,
but I love her, so great.
- Yeah she's great. But it would be like,
if someone continued to call you Carrie,
even after you correct them and say,
actually it's Kelly and
they say, okay, Carrie.
As long as you can understand
how weird it feels,
when someone messes it
up for another person,
then you can kind of understand
how the depth and the
importance of getting it right is,
and that's all it is about.
- [Kelly] That's a
great way to explain it.
- Yeah it's just about
accepting each other,
- Investing, trying. Yeah. Agreed, agreed.
Well, is it true that you
kind of slid, I love this.
You slid into the DMS of a
guest you had on your podcast.
I love this.
Is it true?
- Are we really just
calling me out like that?
- [Kelly] Yes we just really went there.
I love that. You really know who you want.
- I did, I did. Well,
you know, I've always,
even when I identified as female,
I was always sliding in the DM's
like if you don't take your shot,
how are you going to know
if you're going to get it?
- [Kelly] Exactly.
So, yeah, I, slid into
Emily Hampshire's DMS
and she was on Schitt's Creek
- [Kelly] I love Schitt's Creek.
- [Demi] I just think she's so beautiful
and so funny and timing is great.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- [Demi] And then she
was on my podcast and
she brought it up and I was like, "no!"
but it was okay, god I mean look at that.
- I know, she's so cool, she's so funny.
I love that show so much on
my god I was so sad it's over.